okay hey welcome so we're gonna end
today with a very quick 30 minute uh uh
kind of discussion
about no it's gonna be short about uh
assumptions and cryptography and
complexity Theory and I wanna maybe I
should introduce quickly so only Jay
chanetti
and Brian hey okay so I introduced
[Music]
the panel is about assumptions and in
particular really we want to understand
kind of
how are we doing as a field crypto and
complexity uh with regards to assumption
are we too liberal are we too
restrictive uh are there some
assumptions that we consider good
assumptions not good assumptions but I
would really like you guys to take
Liberty and just say really what's on
your mind so in whatever order you guys
choose so it's good it's a
discussion all right my view is that I
think any assumption that can you buy
research is good like for example strong
expensive time versus I know Ryan don't
believe in that maybe I mean that's
probably what he thinks ago I'm not
about now but I think SATs really
inspire a lot of resources so that's
good and uh and also I think uh concrete
assumption that I extremely strong are
also good because I think five people to
refuse them so yeah
of course well I think courses are
different okay okay I will get back to
that
yeah
so
yeah actually I like to uh
uh maybe yeah change the subject and
and say so maybe the point is not so
much the assumptions you know it's the
reductions it's not you know it's it's
not you it's me it's a it's the it
really uh yeah
the uh
yesterday all our results in crypto are
unconditional because uh results are
always a reduction right and it's an
unconditional result about the reduction
and you can plug in Assumption one side
you get another assumption on their side
or you can in uniform assumption not
uniform assumption you can also use it
without any assumptions or just reduce
to use stability like Phil Roger with us
you know and and it's still meaningful
even if there is no you know hardness in
a formal sense so so I think you know
it's good to focus about about
deductions and you said that assumptions
are good if the Fosters new research in
some sense assumptions are good if there
if they you know help you come up with a
good reduction uh so that's you know
maybe my point of view here
I I agree with all of the above
obviously any I I it's hard to think of
of an assumption that is really bad
except unless it obfuscates completely
the pro the problem in which case it's
just not interesting but uh I don't
think that we can that there is anything
that can be called too liberal uh
assumption
the fourth assumption is is also good of
course
uh especially if you can show that it's
false
um I would say that probably we should
try different types of assumptions that
we have been we should expand the type
of assumption that we're not exactly
that this problem is hard but somehow
not that I have any concrete ideas but
somehow make assumptions that you know
this process makes the problem harder or
something of that nature
um yeah so clearly there are cultural
differences between complexity theaters
and cryptographers and um complexity
theorists are probably very conservative
with regard making assumptions and
cryptographers are rather liberal and I
guess it's really a question of meeting
in the middle
not So Much Anymore yeah we're trying to
make the minimals now I guess
um
yeah yeah for example what Leisure
talked about yesterday I mean I think
that's a good Trend because
um we don't usually make assumptions
that easily but then when we make some
new ones that leads to interesting
research
um you get unconditional results
sometimes too from the I mean you might
make a strong assumption but you might
get an unconscious result from it
um but for me I think an important
aspect is also
um like assumptions which have from the
cryptographic side maybe assumptions
that have implications not just for
building crypto systems but are relevant
to foundational issues in other parts of
computer science and we saw in the talks
today at IO is such an assumption which
is clearly relevant to issues across on
the the range and um I think yeah to
also value assumptions for having that
rather than just their applications to
cryptography is a good direction of you
okay
um so I'm a big fan of uh Avi wigerson's
t-shirt that says don't believe
everything you think
okay so what I'd like to say is uh
you know you can make assumptions but
don't assume your assumptions
okay so um so uh you know mentioned the
difference between an assumption and a
hypothesis
um so we the exponential time hypothesis
and strongly exponential time hypothesis
were carefully like labeled hypotheses
rather than conjectures because uh I
also don't believe them I don't
disbelieve them I think they're
interesting whether or not they're true
or false and so it's a question not a
not a really a conjecture okay and I
think the the you know the best
hypotheses or assumptions are those
which are really interesting if they're
true but they're really interesting if
they're faults as well okay so it's just
a question we want to know the answer to
and which and it has a lot of
implications if it's true has a lot of
implications of his faults
um the danger is when we start talking
as if our assumptions are always true
when this happens sometimes in fine
grain complexity but I also see it
happen when people are like saying we we
give the first scheme with provable
security but that provable security is
based on an ad hoc assumption that only
been in that paper so
um
okay
or in the random Oracle model
um
okay if we've seen that that results in
the random Oracle or other Oracle models
can lead to unconditional results later
that doesn't mean that they're not
interesting it just means that we
shouldn't be selling them as if they're
they're fact
some
constructions based on some new
assumptions uh there were like a lot of
famous papers being cited uh in the like
early papers in in IO in functional
encryption that were essentially here's
how we might do it and then we'll just
write down the assumptions that we need
in this paper and I hope that something
like them is true eventually and that's
fine if you just want to establish that
something conceivably might be possible
rather than you're claiming that it is
the case
and so we should be just careful to
distinguish between those those
implications those reductions that are
showing that something conceivably might
be possible right and those assumptions
mean that if this weren't the case
something the whole landscape would
change
so people have touched on a lot of what
I was thinking about saying I guess for
a long time I've uh looked at or viewed
hardness assumptions in a very uh
operational way
um sort of just challenges that when I
think about them they they generate
ideas
um so I'm not trying to build secure
crypto systems and I think everyone is
better off for that so I'm I'm just
trying to get ideas so so often I'm
maybe I'm not even
uh the true or falsity of a hardness
assumption maybe is irrelevant to me
what is relevant is when I think about
it
um like does it does it provoke my
thoughts in in some new direction or get
me to think about things in a different
way and I think yeah Legion briefly
mentioned that
um I I have a
have a long talk where I speak about
different attempts to refute a strong
eth Russell's strong ath and Moana Chris
calabros
um actually I was trying to do that
before it was even called strong eth uh
like as a as a grad student and the
reason why it was that you're trying to
find a CNM set algorithm and running in
1.9 in time and so there's a lot of
other problems that have slightly faster
algorithms but CNF status just ever so
different that you know somehow you've
got to think differently you've got to
have a different approach to solving the
problem uh than
then all the standard methods and
somehow trying to think about all these
different attacks on it led to most of I
guess what I would what I published in
what is now called fine grain uh
complexity
um so yeah I think of them it's a yeah I
don't necessarily think of them as
um you know something I'm trying to
build an edifice on really is but it was
something that's like uh like a muse
almost or like a thought-provoker that
is that is getting me to think in in an
interesting Direction
um but I will say yeah I mean echoing a
bit of what Russell mentioned about
Franklin complexity uh I've observed
that like about hardness assumptions
once they're like in a paper
um so once they're published uh I think
like the general trend is often that
people don't necessarily try to refute
them they try to say oh what can I build
upon this new name topic like this new
named conjecture okay what can I derive
from it rather than I mean okay maybe
they're trying to derive false but but
like instead of like trying to refute it
this seems to be like the maybe the gut
reaction or the the most natural
reaction to things
um that so so in that way you know it
can kind of narrow uh people's Focus
on the other hand
um if you do manage to refute this thing
with a name then you're guaranteed a
paper so so like it does like you know
Focus research in a particular way but I
feel like the default that people have
is to just run with the Assumption
that's there instead of sort of treating
it as like uh just food for thought kind
of uh you know it could be true could be
false not gonna end the world one way or
another but like maybe you know it can
get you to think about new ideas because
I mean yeah for me like new ideas are
like the currency that whatever I'm
always trying to get more like trying to
understand yeah
so I'm going to rip off Ryan so maybe
what we should do is like
every time you make a new assumption put
a new assumption in the literature
okay
you have to put a cash yeah no no you
have to put up a cash prize for the
person who refutes it yeah and so the
bigger your cash prize you know the
bigger the more you're willing to bet on
it the more seriously people will take
it
here we go bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'll see
so I don't think it's such a great idea
for because I I want people to be
liberal with their assumptions and I
want them to be as clear as possible so
that it can be easy to to refute
and cash prizes are go against
question for you guys um
I I actually based on but wait does
anybody want to say something audience
can you know contract that is there an
example where the community went in the
direction of following an assumption and
it was a bad idea in hindsight
maybe some knowledge assumptions yeah no
one talked about knowledge yeah it
wasn't it didn't get so popular maybe
for my time
knowledge yesterday from five to nine
yeah
if he wins
so Ryan you said not enough people are
working on you know Russian games
actually I have to say
you know you better pay for me I don't
know if someone comes up with an
assumption that's if the assumption is
like Russell said if the assumption is
interesting if you're a refuge Factory
yes but if you refuted esoteric
assumption nobody cares you just
essentially found that the previous
paper was less interesting why is it
your job to spend your time and every
Joshua that comes up with an assumption
to try to refute it so I kind of uh you
know so
I agree that on one hand if the
Assumption kind of brings together some
assumptions like I will mentioned brings
together ties together different fields
or kind of shows even in the same field
she kind of shows a little bit
relationship between problems that we
didn't know before behind assumption and
so in some sense even if the assumption
is not we learn on the way relation even
the assumption that we're broken we want
because we learned connections maybe so
I agree with the liberty of making
assumptions
but I think uh hoping that people will
spend time refueling them is over I
don't think they'll be compensated
enough uh and I'm not sure cash prizes
but you know I think that is an issue uh
that we may have even though I I love
assumptions
something about uh to drive with the
acknowledge or something it's a great
example it's really not an assumption
it's it's what it is it's a reduction
with the whole right we have a reduction
and yeah there's one supplement we don't
know how to do so we assume it exists
right so it's a so it's really I
disagree with you
just a feasibility assumption and
complexity May feasibility assumptions
and crypto will make invisible
assumptions of water 5. but but but it's
you know it's this is the kind of like
the liquid essential Northwest cover
assumption you can do it
assuming that you exist you know you
know great work today but this is maybe
a quick essential non-facifiable
assumption but it's like assuming they
exist ill but but go with YouTube right
uh so so uh you know okay if there was a
video
no it's not that this research is not
interesting it's very interesting to
show the power for you but so since it's
not something that I would put with an
assumption in the same line as other
things
three lights
select we've asked you uh what makes an
assumption interesting because in all of
this
like it's easy to come upload some
assumptions but when do we know we're
making progress knowing release
[Laughter]
so I have
Benchmark which is I'm at the complexity
one if the assumption is very very
simple and short then it's a worthwhile
thing to to study and that's it I take a
very personal review of these things
besides if it's shorts then it's fine to
put it up there and otherwise
for instance as Russian was saying they
thought that it's not a particularly
useful thing before yeah
I think everyone already people didn't
realize how interesting it is
it took a while
and
I know from introducing when telling
people about it they're sure that it's
completely useless
until they tell them how useful it is
we just don't know the that doesn't
contradict rafels
Benchmark no oh okay
as a mother how should I think the
solution with frustration is is easy to
State yeah it's easy to straight so it's
hard to argue
[Music]
then you just have to do something with
it before it becomes very interesting
and once you do the first thing with it
we didn't know what to do before
yeah that's the historical status
matters too right IO has already defined
by Defiance I mean the fact was this is
necessarily independently interesting a
long time ago and in general I think
assumptions about problems that have
been considered before are more
interesting I mean if we Define a new
problem and then make an assumption
about it I mean that's the kind of thing
you might do to prove something very
specific
there are many holes by the many
historical coincidences that decide
which problems are looked at and we
don't have a good coverage it's not
going to cover everything but it gives
maybe some more weight to an assumption
if it's not a problem that's been
answered before
okay
um Simplicity is always with respect to
some Universal turing machine and it
differs and
um that really history
depends on you know the Simplicity
depends on the history because what the
concepts that are already fresh in your
mind
seem simpler than learning something new
no matter how accurate kind of
objectively simple it is so
um so I have to like say I'm not sure
I'm a fan of the Simplicity
um measure because so something like a
definition of zero knowledge or
non-interactive zero knowledge has a
number of quantifiers it's longer than
most of the things that appeared in the
literature before something like uh
security against adaptive chosen
ciphertext attack takes a while to get
right uh so he is really like more the
implications than I think the Simplicity
that matter
foreign
well what people assumed was it was
impossible
um
so
yes just assuming that it was CCA secure
I mean what I think what happened is
people
yes and correct me if I'm wrong people
were just like using intuitive Notions
of secure encryption and signature and
then different protocols that were built
using these undefined assumptions got
broken or were shown to have holes and
that's when people refined their their
reductions find their definitions
refined uh
the uh
the assumptions that they built that
they used to to build these things
so
um
yeah so like
uh yeah you know
encryption using braid groups is really
simple if you're a break group theorist
and we have This Acronym method where
everything is like it's most stem
litters it's very short
okay so we talked a lot about
assumptions and on the other side of
assumptions we have conclusions
and then so actually in rahulstok we
heard about some conclusions like it's
visit constructions of combinatorial
objects that try to be a toilet object
some of which still do not follow
from nice assumptions even very strong
assumptions
that are not ad hoc they were tailored
to the actual primitive we saw that the
rage range avoidance problem which could
have been such a you know a good
assumption
it does not quite work so do you have
any proposal for a very strong Uber
assumption that implies basically
everything we want at least in the
context of the randomization related the
context and explicit constructions or do
you have some other conclusions that you
wish that they could be derived from so
basically a wish list for assumptions
that serve specific conclusions which we
cannot still derive from anything nice
yeah I mean I think one example is
assumption that um you can generate and
say time out of the 100
um a string is incompressible with
respect to n to the 10 time algorithms
that's a very strong assumption which
implies all these exclusive
constructions I mean the Congo random
strings itself an explosive instruction
for any reasonable motion expensive
construction you want with polynomial
time possibility and um I don't think
it's been like properly started before
so I think that's yeah it's stronger
than circular bound assumptions
um it's kind of a bit weaker in a range
of oil and some in between and so we
could still believe that it's it's true
um so that's something I think
I guess something maybe a little
stronger than that it's range avoidance
but for a uniform like circuits like
which can be constructed from a
polynomial time algorithm
um but yeah I I don't really know
whether to believe
uh this is MP or not but I mean it will
be like that would still imply
essentially all of the nice uh
conclusions so
okay
uh let me mention some assumptions like
if you have a sample distribution of
render evidence instances then you have
a dismissive heuristic with respect to
this sample distribution uh I think it's
it seems still like a plausible
assumption although I don't know
yes you can justify those assumptions in
the random Oracle model so in a random
model you can actually still bring the
avoidance is nothing FP but oh but uh
for uniform anniversary it's actually
you just pick a random string I mean I'm
not sure that how interesting is that
but uh yeah it is that can be kind of
some
what type of conclusion and assumption
so one conclusion I want to say to
understand the optimality of
randomization so assuming something
called NSD th it's a very strong
assumption and you can show every key
time some T time randomized algorithm
cannot be der randomized without
overhead less than M so I want my
interesting question is to find out some
part of assumption to see to get the
same conclusion or actually to get
better generalization this is something
like kind of fundamental because you
really want to understand that which
degree you want to generalization and
but it still seems to be very unexployed
yeah maybe you can use IO to show this
but I don't know
stuff
is it clear that you couldn't even cheer
that unconditionally like uh like guys
as as far as I know it is amazing I
might be able to do it using like uh
unconditionally right okay I mean you
have a fooling sound low about right
some problem cannot be de randomized uh
but you're saying you're saying there's
something that if you solved at the time
random rst event which you cannot tell
them
oh I think so if you connected to be I
don't know if I can talk about you know
Finding majority you have a screening
with promise
so we have to focus on T which is super
ninja yeah but uh so okay
well we don't we don't know
instead of this being a complexity Zoo
obtained creatures this would be a
complexity jungle
but yeah
yeah but speaking of jungle if I could
just say one more thing about
assumptions I mean I think like one
aspect of assumptions which I quite like
is when there are exotic assumptions
assumptions that don't fit into the
picture of the world we have easily and
I think IO is an example as we saw it
doesn't fit into the boxes as well as
easily or even like assumptions like
keyless resident hash functions and a
one-way permutation yes yes yeah I mean
just to yeah it might not be clear how
much you can do with these but they sort
of open up our kind of like imagination
somehow in terms of how well we actually
understand uh yeah just if I know
connecting leads is the point about
random oracles with the discussions
about unconditionally
proofs right so we saw that in handling
stock and in Alexis stock two examples
of unconditional cryptographic results
in generic models right and ick in the
random Oracle Model A Witness encryption
using the generic multilinear maps that
have complexity Theory replication so
even you know an conditional prefix is
not about assumptions but
the information Theory crypto or generic
model crypto has a interesting
processary yeah
okay so I guess uh there is a lot more
to say and we can take a further
discussions
let's think all the panelists and
out